- I don't mind the ads.
I don't mind the buffer, but
when the ads buffer I suffer.
That's good.
You may be a poet, and not even know it.
(upbeat music)
Haven't done a responding
to comments video
in quite a long time so I'm excited
to see what questions you have for me.
I'm going to be tackling health
questions and fun questions.
Bee-woop!
Cuhleef, your shirt is tight that you
look like an intelligent stripper.
(laughs) Actually, Rachel
Ray said that to me once.
She said I look like a
Chip N Dale's dancer.
Yeah, I like my shirts fitted.
You can show off your physique,
everything I work for in
the gym, in the kitchen.
By the way, I'm vegan right now.
It sucks.
I mean, I didn't say anything yet.
You'll see the results in my three-day
vegan video coming soon.
Matt Kenny, what's the deal with your
presentation at South by South West?
How come we didn't see it?
It was actually an awesome presentation.
I partnered with Vox Media and 3M
talking about the power of silence.
I did a whole video
dedicated to the subject.
The idea of silence
needs to be incorporated
in our lives and 3M is making
some amazing strides
in making this happen.
Like, they even talked about on stage how
they make our commute
quieter so we can have
time to ourselves in the car when we're
not being attacked by employees
and job duties and social media.
I think the brain needs
silence every now and then.
Tailor: how tight do you want your shirt?
Mike: yes.
(laughs) Okay, I do take
my stuff to the tailor.
Some stuff, actually this
is fresh out the bag.
Out the bag!
Y Ella, Ella, Ella.
I think that's a Beyonce song,
or no, Rihanna oops.
I have a question. I've been
getting my period for three
weeks straight, is that all right?
Ella, that is not all right.
There is something abnormal going on.
Good reason to talk to your
doctor about your cycle.
Questions that you should
be prepared to answer,
how long has this been going on?
How long do your cycles last regularly?
Are they regular?
Are they irregular?
Are you sexually active?
Is it possible that you may be pregnant?
If you come ready with all of these
questions in mind,
it'll make for an easier
doctor's visit for you.
James stfu, I know what
that stands for James.
Yo Mike, I know you're a Russian spy, bro.
I'm watching you.
No I'm not, bro because
if you would've known
I would've already ended you.
Trust me, not a spy.
I like it here much better.
Yeah, Mike works hard but
his shirt works harder.
What's with the shirt stuff man?
Stop getting on me.
Why do you think I wear a tie?
It's because the buttons
are about to say peace.
(laughs)
Bagofcheetos s, he attack, he's a snack,
but most importantly he got nurses' back.
Damn right I got my nurses' back.
I defend them.
Shout out to all the nurses I work with
and CMAs cause y'all
don't get enough love.
I don't know why I'm doing this accent.
Maybe because I did that.
Proz Kirby, can you do a
vide on premature graying?
I need to do that sadly.
I don't know if you can tell,
I'm premature graying.
I'm in my 20s and I have gray hair.
Sad.
Sonia, collab with Glam Gore please.
This is happening.
We have exchanged Twitter messages.
I love her content,
it's super fun to watch.
I really want to collab but I do know
she's taking a personal, mental, physical
health break from YouTube
which is totally awesome.
I support creators in doing this.
They know themselves,
they know their limits.
Hey Dr. Mike, what's the correct way
to stop a bloody nose?
Tilting my head back
and swallowing the blood
makes me nausueous, thanks.
That is true, Annika.
You do not want to tilt your head back
because swallowing that
blood will not only
make you nauseous, but it can wreck havoc.
Wreck havoc?
It can wreak havoc on
your digestive system
causing diarrhea or constipation.
So, what I recommend for my patients to do
is to tilt their head forward,
pinch at the base of
the nose and if you get
something cold there too, that will help
because ideally what you want to do
is pinch the blood vessels
off so that less blood
gets to the area and
therefore you'll be better.
Another little life hack, you could get
a nasal spray like one
of those constricting
nasal sprays for congestion,
spray one of those
bad boys in and it'll
shrink the blood vessels
and therefore you're going
to have less blood flow
and you'll lose less blood.
Peter Olah, hi Mike I'm just wondering
what car slash cars do you own?
Peter, great questions because
I absolutely love cars.
I'm actually driving
my childhood dream car
at the moment, an Audi R8 Spider.
It's actually funny to say that
because I used to have an
Audi TTS back in the day.
I crashed that car because of a spider.
I have to tell that story
on my channel at some point.
If you're interested, hit
it below in the comments.
Unicorn love, hey doc I feel hard and wet
down there even when doing
simple, common things.
May I know why?
I love your videos.
Some of us get attracted
to things and that's okay.
What?
Myself times two, what are your thoughts
on women choosing female doctors?
Do you think it is silly to be shy
about seeing male doctors?
I don't want to say it's
silly because everyone's
entitled to have their own thoughts
and anxieties and so forth,
but I have spoken to women and recently
as you'll see soon in our collab video,
I spoke to Molly Burk.
- I don't even want to think about it.
I will actually say I
prefer when men do it.
I find that because they
don't know the feeling.
They'll never know it.
They can't experience it.
- So you think they're extra careful?
- They're more sensitive.
- In my practice, we try and instill
the fact to our patients
that each of our doctors
is well trained and
capable of seeing any sex
but if they have a very strong preference
we'll try and accommodate
to the best of our ability.
E Cruz, eat a can of
Pringles and go to the sauna.
Yeah.
I don't quite get it.
I love saunas, though.
I'm actually going to
make a Wednesday checkup
dedicated to saunas if you're game.
You game?
Hit me in the comments.
Sauna, me, Pringles.
No Pringles, just me, sauna, yeah.
Anna Hurn, if you had
to move another country
where would you move to?
Love your videos, by the way.
Thank you.
Oh, where would I move?
I would like to move somewhere where they
speak English as a first language
because that will help.
I like Australia.
I like their climate, it's warm.
There's lots of sunshine.
Pretty isolated, so bad
people can't get you.
I don't know where I'm going with this.
Australia, that's my answer.
Goldenteegenter, is it okay to sleep
with a fan pointed at you?
I heard it can cause a
stroke of some sorts.
This is really good.
I don't recommend having
any kind of cold air
blowing on you for an
extended period of time
including air conditioner or fan
or a window open even
while you're driving a car.
The reason being is if
you overcool a muscle
in your neck, let's say
if the fan's blowing
on your neck all night and you constantly
have this cooling sensation on your neck
and you're already
sweating because it's hot,
you're going to overcool that muscle.
You're going to get less blood flow
to the muscle so it's going to constrict
and get really angry. So, when
you wake up and you use it
and it spasms on you you're
going to have a very stiff neck.
So, one of the first
questions I ask my patients
that come in with a stiff neck is did you
just drive for a very long period of time
with the windows open, have
the AC blow on you, or a fan?
It happens quite often.
Beastgirl, do weighted blankets
really help with anxiety?
Please like so he can see
I really want to know.
Do they treat anxiety, no.
I mean, let's be realistic.
If it was that simple, I would just be
prescribing anxiety or weighted
blankets to all my patients.
I think what I like
about weighted blankets
is there's some kind of innate human
feeling of having
something a little heavier
on you that the blanket's not going to jut
fly off and it's warm.
Personally, I like heavier blankets
even in the summer when it's hot.
I think making claims that they help
with medical or mental health
conditions is going too far.
Arynickson, I think Dr.
Mike is not named Mike.
I'm not.
My true name is actually
Mikhail Varshavski.
I wonder if people knew that.
Luis Herrerra, hi Dr. Mike can you explain
the whole man flu phenomenon?
Do men experience signs and symptoms
worse compared to women?
I have heard this somewhere
and there was a study
talking about how men complain more
about their symptoms or when they have the
same exact symptoms say
that it effects them more.
Why this happens, I'm not sure.
I want to say that men are babies,
but I feel like I'm being unfair to men.
I would say I have witnessed this.
I also will say that men don't like
going to see the doctor so that if they're
coming to see me, something
really must be wrong
or a woman in their lives have encouraged
them to go see a doctor.
Frank Mazzarese, Dr. Mike,
what your blood type?
I'm A minus.
I don't know what my blood type is
but I think if it should be anything
it should be A positive because I'm
an A positive student, ha.
B positive because I want to be positive.
Okay, moving on.
David Ivascu, you should do
a collab with James Charles.
He would adore you so much, he will
probably want to marry you.
David, I appreciate the compliment
and I'm a fan of James Charles.
Him and I have also Dmed.
He's a pretty awesome human for being 19
years old and accomplished everything
he's accomplished, it's really impressive.
Especially being a positive person.
Diana Capano, hi Dr. Mike.
I'm a recent nursing
school grad and we touched
upon the ethical issues of slow codes.
What is your personal perspective
on the issue and did they
talk about this in med school?
Diana, great question. For
those of you who don't know,
slow codes is when someone's heart stops
and they call a code
blue and they essentially
are dead and you have to revive them.
Slow codes is when you
believe that a patient
shouldn't be revived and the patient
or the patient's family
is making a bad decision
where you don't necessarily do everything
you can to revive them
because you don't think
it's in their best interest.
I'm not a fan of this, personally.
I think everyone has a
choice in their healthcare
and if they choose to make
that choice on their own
or they choose to have the
families make that decision
I think that's their right.
It's their prerogative.
That's just my two cents.
Question, why do I keep
getting cold sores?
Do I know what I can do to make them stop
or why I even get them?
Well, generally speaking if
you're getting cold sores
you have herpes, it's herpes simplex.
It's a virus that stays
dormant inside your body
unless it breaks out in
a form of a cold sore.
Now, if you got one cold sore that means
the virus is with you for life
and will occasionally pop
out when you're stressed,
when you have a weakened immune system
like if you have a virus,
a bacterial infection,
and so forth.
My recommendation to you would be talking
to your doctor about how you can stay
as healthy as possible which is focusing
on all your lifestyle habits and then
if you're still getting
outbreaks very often
you can talk about a medication
which is an antiviral medication
which prevents this outbreaks and you can
take it daily, not just
when you have an outbreak
in order to reduce the number of outbreaks
that you do get.
Dom The Alien, have you seen an increase
in patients or people trying to become new
patients since you started your channel?
I have seen that.
It doesn't happen as often as you'd think.
More often what happens is a patient
is in a room, I walk in
and they're so surprised
to see me because they
watch the YouTube channel
but them reaching out on their own
doesn't happen often and in general
I tend to not accept new patients
because my patient panel is so full.
There's plenty of great
doctors in my practice
that are accepting new patients.
I think you're going to love this playlist
that I created just for you.
My favorite videos of 2019
so far, click it, click it.
Stay happy and healthy.
(Lo fi music)